and we are off some old Pokemon cards I
have no idea I'm actually not educated
enough on Pokemon believe it or not to
know if I did well here or not look
there's an extraordinary amount of
education required to be good at this
game you can obviously look up on
your phone on the spot but one thing
that I love to do is teach people to
like go out and do it on the second or
third time after you're done doing it
play the game you got to do the push-ups
but now after three times you've got a
sense of what you see often now you go
to eBay and you go to completed items
and you type in that thing that I think
is a real help like getting used to what
you're seeing at these garage sales to
then be able to go and hit the search
and eBay of the common things you see
and you're hitting completed items and
now you're figuring out like what the
value of certain things are and you keep
building from there